i want to talk about akash singh and
he's right up in the new york times oh
okay we got here
we out here wait britney [ __ ] y'all
no y'all got time akash one how did it
how does it feel yeah it was really cool
can we tell the can we tell the story
can we tell the real story yeah yeah
yeah okay bust it down okay so we tried
to get our costs
we told the real story they tried to get
you can't get this man i don't
get this man
i read the whole [ __ ] angry all right so
i got asked if i want to do a uh an
article in the new york times somebody
want to do a write-up on me i'm not sure
if it's a rogan thing or what you got to
be a little bit nervous and i go in i'm
talking to this guy his credit he was he
was arguing with me about [ __ ] i had
never done an interview like that okay
every interview i've done not many but
they ask you a question you give an
answer and they move on to the next
question this guy and i talked for like
two hours and he's pushing back on [ __ ]
he keeps bringing up hurry and i'm like
i don't i didn't make this special about
her he has nothing to do with hurry i
don't want to talk about hari and he's
like well you can't not talk about this
special without talking about that you
just let people know who harry kondabal
is going to bother for those of you who
don't know he's the guy that made the
special that got a poo taken off the air
essentially the problem with a poo yes
and my reaction was not to him it was to
this whole thing like we can take a poo
off the air really that's what we're
reaching for is brown people which he
plays a part in yeah so i did but at the
time i'm also very wary of like being
painted as like this right wing like we
joke here right wing sing but everybody
listening knows me they have context i
have to be very guarded about people
trying to make me some kind of like
right wing like brown candace owens type
thing i don't want that [ __ ] at all
so we we're kind of going back and forth
and then we start arguing about
something and then he says something
like well there's two camps of comedy
right there's the woke camp and then
your camp the anti-wolf camp and i'm
like whoa i'm not that i'm not woke at
all but like i'm not in some anti-vote
camp where i all i do is [ __ ] that's not
my i i don't care about it that much
yeah and then you're singing i'm awkward
so then he and i legit start arguing in
this [ __ ] tea house we just start
like arguing at some point because i say
to him no no i resent what you're saying
right now because you're too smart to do
this you're too smart to paint me as one
of these guys and i know people want to
paint me as one of these guys but i'm
not that like i'm not doing like glenn
beck asked me to do an interview i'm not
gonna do glenn beck and he looks
surprised for a second he's like you
wouldn't do glenn beck and i was like
[ __ ] no i'm not gonna do look i'll do it
if i do rachel maddow and i'm doing both
but i'm not gonna do it
yeah just to make money either side i'm
not that guy and i think he had
an idea of me being completely polar
opposite of hariko nabalu i think in his
mind
was just like well this guy seems to
completely disagree with him so he must
be this other guy i don't begrudge him
for it i just think we had a
misunderstanding and i also think his
interview style to be fair to him i
don't want to [ __ ] on him i think he
just picks out what you're saying to get
context but i had never done an
interview like that so i'm like this
[ __ ] out here trying to get me
yo yeah
i was yo that's him right there yeah but
i was going he said something like you
had alex jones on your podcast and i go
i don't think we need to talk about that
here because again i don't want him to
take the thing there yeah and then he
goes well i can't talk about you without
mentioning that you had alex jones on
your podcast and i go i think you can
so like i'm pretty almost like he had a
preconceived notion of who you were and
every time you were creating pushback
for that notion he was trying to find
another way to justify it that's that's
why i was upset and i could have been i
called him afterward we talked after
when he cleared the air he was like look
my style is i'm going to push back to
get context on who you are and i
realized what i was thinking is this
[ __ ] is exactly that i want to
give him credit i think he's just he
would do this with anybody like if
you're a left-wing guy he's going to
give you a right-wing point of view just
to see what you dig deeper on what you
really think
and then by the end of it he talked to
me about like so you seem like a pretty
moderate guy is it tough to do comedy
that way etc and that didn't necessarily
make him the piece but i respected that
he asked me he said you were moderate
left-leaning yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know he said yeah if you were
that that's true yeah and i do like that
he said i heatedly bulked at the notion
of being an anti-whole comic like put
that [ __ ] in i do not [ __ ] want that
i thought the piece was good yeah and i
thought the piece exposed that you had
an answer for every potential criticism
of you so i'll give him credit in that
regard is that like he was he was
feeding you lines that some people might
have been deflated yeah if they had to
respond to like that could have you know
kind of hung a lot of people out to dry
but you've thought about this so much
more than the average person so there's
no way that they're going to put you in
this position where you're going to be
this radioactive polarizing figure about
these and to be fair to anybody who
interviews me you
you should if i haven't thought it
through like that i shouldn't put out
the special i shouldn't put out a
special call bring back a poo if i
haven't thought this through at every
level
now i'm comfortable i stand on this
so i don't yo i was heated when i left
that interview i was like down what the
[ __ ] i called andrew i was like i think
his [ __ ] tried to get me
whatever yeah i emailed him then he was
like yo i'm sorry you feel that way
genuinely don't give me a call you want
to clear up the air and i called him and
then we did find a place where he's like
look if you don't like the article
that's fine that is your right and i
understand is nerve-wracking to be
written about because you don't have
control of it but just can you do me one
favor and just read the article first
and i was like yeah you got me yeah i
think you got me on that like read it
before it comes out no just read it
before you rush to judgment and tell me
i slandered you or whatever like don't
do it
no that's fair yeah i mean look i can
feel the way but i have no images don't
go on yeah you read it first yeah but
the guy you were right the good thing is
we have this platform right if he did
slander me to be like yo this
[ __ ] full of [ __ ] whatever we
can fight back against my only issue is
is the fact that it kind of seemed like
he went into this uh this interview with
a preconceived notion of who you were
and he seemed like he was trying to
justify that preconceived notion and i
honestly i'm only getting this from what
you shared with me yeah if that's how he
felt i'm glad he felt that way because
he's smart enough that we can have an
argument and i can give him all the
counters and then he can put that in his
piece because he did his job as a
reporter which is put out an honest
piece yeah so
as much as i want to be emotional about
it i'm glad that guy who's a reporter
who's going to be honest in his actual
piece felt that way because then let's
let's have this argument and then you
write your piece on it yeah and it feels
natural to have a preconceived notion
right like yeah any person who has that
you watch someone's content and you're
like oh i wonder if this is what this
person's like then you know anything
i think if you actually watch someone's
content you wouldn't have a preconceived
notion that was that wrong
that's that's my feeling i think that
like if you were a fan of someone's work
that you would have a more like nuanced
view
and hopefully that was the one thing
that's the one thing i pushed back on is
he told me you heard my rogan i'm like
yo you heard my rogan then you did it
yeah yeah yeah he brought that up he was
like yo you brought this thing up in
rogan where you said the woke movement
is overall leading to a good place it
comes from a good place or something
like that like so it was it was a
[ __ ] it's an intense thing when
you're sitting with somebody for two
hours and just disagreeing and then you
walk away thinking this motherfucker's
gonna write something about me and we
had intense disagreements in that two
hours it wasn't all disagreement but
like there were moments where i'm like
bro i don't know yeah i don't know what
the [ __ ] this guy does he just wants to
zone in on that part he just wants his
own on that part now again to andrew's
point i've thought this all through so
you can come at me with this and if you
actually want to talk you're not going
to find a lot of holes in my logic i'm
not completely right at all but like
i've thought it through so i thought he
he did his job but i walked out of there
being very uncomfortable with just like
i don't know what happened dude this is
the [ __ ] new york times i do know
they lean left and i probably am a
slightly left-leaning guy but like i'm
not you know i'm not i don't want to be
painted in any [ __ ] light that i'm
not that's not authentic so i walked out
of there like
i don't know what just happened but then
it came when i read the article i was
like yo this is cool i like that it was
more about you than about the special
yeah like we were talking about this the
other day and uh
and and giannis actually had a really
funny clip where he agreed with
everything you said about like there's
no point in having like comedy reviewers
yeah like like the audience reviews yeah
we don't need a reviewer right like we
just need the audience and if the
audience is laughing then those people
find it funny yeah that's why i like
that the article is more about like you
and your opinions about this topic right
so writing about a comic and like what
they mean and what their messaging is
and what the point of a special like
that is great yeah but like judging
whether a comic is funny or not is like
we don't need
yeah were they laughing yeah yeah and he
didn't do that and he he he
diametrically opposed me to harry gonna
bother more than i would have wanted
necessarily because again and i'm glad
he included in the end that i i think
he's a funny guy and he's a good joke
writer and he's hard-working like i
don't want to sit here and make it a
[ __ ] beef yeah i mean that's not
that's not we'll have hari on the pot i
would yeah sorry if you ever want to
come on the pot and discuss apu or other
things let's do it with akash we are
more than welcome
uh to having you here yeah okay
absolutely open discussion you feel a
little bit better though oh yeah
when i read it i was like yo this piece
is good my parents read it they were
proud like that's another thing to them
this is the biggest this is bigger than
a self-produced special on youtube to
them for sure yeah even if a million
people saw it they're like yo this is
the new york times it should mean
something i send this to india to our
family and they're like holy [ __ ] yeah
at that point to older folks like that's
people were driven to theaters and to
yeah you know movies and specials from
like the new york times like calendar
and arts and entertainment section it's
different now obviously and andrew's
speaking from the point of like you can
drive drive it yourself and older
immigrant cultures are they need
validation from the outside because
that's how the world functions for them
this is this is everybody it's like uh
yeah the stamp of approval
you know especially for older
generations comes from like when uh
institutions
coast on you yeah right like uh you know
older people probably saw the netflix
special that we did and they were like
oh my god this guy has made it yeah not
realizing that like they're far more
like lucrative endeavors that we've done
that just didn't have that name same
thing with new york times lucrative and
profile driving yes of course but there
is something nice about getting access
to something that you know not that many
people have access to yeah right like
there's a gatekeeper to be in the new
york times yeah and then you were chosen
and you created a piece that regardless
of that person wanted to write a
critical piece or a fluff piece i mean
you made sure that it was the piece that
yeah was based on like how you felt so
that was up to you but like regardless
of what that whatever that dude's
sentiment was going into it you created
a piece that should have been written
about and that's pretty awesome yeah i'm
uh yeah again i'm proud and keep in mind
you created it and put on youtube yeah
like that is power to the creator right
you put a piece out on an open platform
and it was so provocative and successful
that the new york times is reviewing
a youtube piece yeah so to me that's the
changing of the guard right there yeah
and that testament to you that's that's
this guy that created the model that's a
question for you guys what's the thing
real quick i was slandered a little bit
they said i'm 38 i'm not 38 for two more
months so new york times i expect a
retraction see and i didn't do his
research doesn't even know who you are
printed apology i might have told him
i'm 38 because i'd be rounding up but
point is
the point is you know i mean do some
googling you know
[Applause]
you